it's actually not my job to answer your
questions I've asked you two questions
should a mass stay in power and are they
a terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that on TV on on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
TV tonight on p on sensor he's a
bestselling author a rockstar stock
broker and a master salesman just about
everybody knows him as the real wolf of
wol Street Jordan bfor gives his
blistering verdict on the economy on
Trump's comeback on working with Leo and
Margo Robbie and how much of that movie
was not only true but could be made
today The Wolf of Wall Street the real
one is
[Music]
uncensored so Jordan well great to see
you first of all it's been 11 years
since I last interviewed you at CNN the
movie just came out right Wolf Wall
Street had just come out your life was
literally exploding in a way you didn't
really understand or what was going to
happen but what's been it your life like
since then you know the movie and it was
a special movie Leo Mar brilliant fil
rible job and uh it just became like the
greatest the biggest cult hit one of the
biggest in history and uh um and I am
grateful for that and I you know again
it was great to have that platform and I
used that to really build my business of
speaking and mentoring around the world
I've written other books since new one
now investing but uh it's been a wild
ride to say the least you know but I'm
more grounded this time more grounded
well you got look a lot different you're
looking good n the it was $400 million
at the box office but I think it took a
lot more elsewhere right right well you
know again the Box offs did great but it
was the single most pirated movie in
history that year beat Frozen it was
like I think 200 million illegal
downloads there is an irony about a
movie about you being the most PIR in
history there two reasons for that
number one because it was you had to be
over 18 or 17 to watch it so a lot of
kids download it and also in many
countries because of all the cursing
there's 506 fbom right you know the
movie was like 50 minutes long in a lot
of Islamic countries they couldn't air a
lot of it to watch the real movie you
had to watch it online by illegally
downloading so and then it just kept
going and going and became this massive
cult there was songs written about me in
the movie just never would have expected
that but I'm grateful for it you know
the when I watched it again the other
day and I thought I might interview you
uh when I came here it was fascinating
to me to think about when you were in
your office environment at its craziest
how you would possibly have survived
today's world
today's human resource control World
today's cancel culture world you know
you think about a woman who shaved her
head in the office in the in the room
for $10,000 to get breast implants the
dwarf brought in to be thrown at a bcro
dart board probably go over to well
today right Jonah Hill you know his
character eating a goldfish which I know
did happen uh etc etc right uh when you
look at it you chuckle about what would
have happened today listen you know on
some level right A lot of the stuff that
that doesn't happen anymore it's good in
some level but on some level it's bad
because we also had a hell of a lot of
fun in process people loved going to
work there so I think on some of this
woke stuff is taking fun out of the
workplace offices have become the most
boring places on God's Earth you used to
go there and lot of people meet their
their their their ultimate life M 40% of
people used to meet their spouse exactly
at work what happens now I don't how
does it even online I guess right but I
mean it's insane you got to be so
careful nowadays right we just got very
boring I mean when you look at what your
life was like I know you've cleaned up
your act but have we just got very
boring I think that the death of
everything started with the smartphone
you know you used to be a to kind of
like Get Away with stuff like it wasn't
being cated photographed and posted
online social media has turned
everything into basically you know a
fishbowl and aess poool would you have
felt muted by a cell phone I I think so
but I can't imagine us being any
different than we were We Were Young and
Wild and you know I've watched it slowly
incrementally get you know more saying
the world so to speak then it just got
went nuts with all the woke stuff you
know and and it was necessary some of it
some of the stuff was me too was
necessary but a lot of it it's like
anything else is wild over correction it
goes to the other side and you know it's
got to now hopefully it's starting to
make its way back to the middle so
hopefully we'll end up in a better
version of what we once had which was
the fun without you know some of the
madness but still some man think is
still good when you go out and about and
you're in a restaurant or a bar or
whatever is there just a constant
pressure from people for you to be that
guy like people you know you know listen
people always come up to me and they're
always really nice and they love the
movie they love the books they love my
speeches um but a lot of them say like
you know was it really that crazy like
it was worse we were wild well you told
me last time I think it was maybe your
bachelor party that something happened
that was so depraved you couldn't even
tell me on air yeah and even though it's
on YouTube this show is called
unsensitive yeah it's so bad you I
really I I got to say you know I have a
wife now for the last four years great
young beautiful amazing wife does she
know what it was thankfully when we
first met she she spoke Spanish not
English now she speaks fluent English
right so you know in the beginning she
couldn't quite figure it out but I think
now she's like I don't even want to know
but there's people still missing from my
bachelor party I think we never found
like know 15 years ago 25 years ago no
one knows where they are but you know it
was pretty wild you said a really thing
last time we met and it was that uh we
spent a lot of time with Leo DiCaprio
and apart from the fact he'd never taken
drugs and you had to show him what it's
like when you're off your head on
quelles uh which he managed to replicate
very convincingly from what I hear um
but it was interesting to me you were
talking about there was a quote I read
to you from from Leo in which he had
completely accepted that there were two
Jordan belfalls right life before
incarceration and life after after
incarceration he'd absolutely respected
that Journey you'd been on and was
incredibly praiseworthy about you as a
human being which meant a lot to you at
the time did yeah but you do you get
that from everyone or are there still a
lot of people who say you know what I
watched the movie and it's fine but
there were a lot of people that you took
to the cleaners yeah with your criminal
activity and we shouldn't be celebrating
Someone Like You Do you still get that
or not a lot less after the crisis you
know 2008 2009 right I think people have
come to realize that Wall Street is a
very dangerous place and it's you know
it's very hard pressed to find any firm
that you know if you look at for example
any great financial crime you know who's
in the middle usually Goldman Sachs
right that's not to say they don't do
great things as well and this book that
I wrote about that like CU Wall Street
is massively corrupt right it's an
unlevel playing field that you know puts
the little guy at a huge disadvantage
yet Wall Street still creates massive
value and it's necessary for the economy
so the question is how do you
participate how do you extract your fair
share of the value That Wall Street
creates without getting sucked into the
dark side which I was once a part of and
get your money either takeen from you
quickly or slowly or just get bled dry
by engaging in things they recommend
like short-term training people I know
that that knew you uh in your Heyday you
said the thing about Jordan was he would
have been a billionaire anyway without
any criminal activity you were that good
as a Trader as a guy that understood
money that you didn't ever need to cross
that line and you talk very openly and
honestly about crossing the line I'm not
going to Rel legislate all that but it
was interesting to me that people felt
you had that natural thing and your
success as a sort of motivational
speaker and advisor and you write these
hugely popular books and so on when you
read them you think well this guy's just
really smart right and you are well I
thank my parents for that but you know I
think yeah it's true and I think the sad
part is if I wouldn't have like taken
that left turn Al Albuquerque so to
speak right I probably would have made
like 10 or 20 billion because I would
have hit the internet bubble right and I
was taking companies public so yeah like
and I think one of the lessons and it's
not in this book this is more on how to
invest your money wisely without getting
sucked in but in other books I've read I
speak about like one of the biggest
mistakes people make is that yeah you
could cut a few corners and make money a
little bit quicker but the big money the
real big money that takes time and you
can't cut Corners because if you do
there's something you can cut but I mean
but I mean you can't just go if you're
not giving value to people if you're not
providing some massive value that's not
going to be sustainable to make the
billions you got to be giving value and
you can always monetize value but you
got to be giving value somebody watching
this who may be likes to dabble a bit in
stocks and shares and so on um maybe a
Better Property whatever it may be what
is the best way to be successful with
money to beat the system which is so
skewed against the ordinary guy so this
is really simple and this is what the
book is about so property is a separate
issue here but talking about stocks like
you know there's two parts of money okay
you got to make a certain amount of
money right and you also have to not
spend more than you make that's like
sort of the budgeting side of things
right but assuming that you make some
amount of money of some bit left over
whether it's small large the real
question is what do you do with that
money how do you put that money to work
in the markets so that when you're ready
to retire one day you have a giant Nest
Egg waiting for you and the irony is
that all the things that you might think
you should do are what you shouldn't be
doing like for example trying to find a
young winning stock and then you know
buy it and sell it and make a big profit
or time the market or you know which
sector should I be all that stuff is
just work human beings by Nature are
terrible stock Pickers we sell when we
should buy we buy when we should sell
the simple way is you want to buy the
entire Market is an index the
S&P you want to buy it and hold it and
you could start with a little bit of
money or a lot of could be $10,000 it
could be a million dollar right but the
key is you want to make a little
contributions every month every quarter
right and let time do the heavy what
about okay but what about the Warren
Buffett way that's his way well his way
he actually believes he he studies
individual companies very very carefully
right and then he invests for the long
term in companies that he believes are
very well-run right and have a regular
cash flow so people you know American
Express Coca-Cola all that kind of stuff
and he one of the wealthiest investors
in history um is that is that really
what you're talking about where you
choose I he choose he has a portfolio of
stocks but he's in there for the very
long term that's exactly what I'm
talking about if you ask Warren Buffett
he says this exact thing I did ask him
and that's what he said bu buy the S&P
500 bu all the best companies and hold
them for the longterm how many should
you have all of them there 500 that's
right all 500 you buy it in one trade
it's most economical bu you buy the
whole shank buy all of them why but
that's not what Warren does it it on
some level it is now again he only has
like like under 20 stocks he owns right
there's there there's a difference
though there are about may be three or
four people in the world that can beat
the S&P 500 he's one of them all these
other hedge funds and mutual funds they
don't even beat the index each year on
average they underperform the index and
after all their fees and commissions and
performance bonuses it's okay but this
want I throw back here part of the thing
of being a investor in the stock market
is the fun of it it's a bit like beding
on horses right right you're sucking the
fun out of it with this strategy no cuz
you're saying just put it all into this
thing yeah nothing you know it's not
going to all you'll see is that one
index fluctuating in value right up and
down and probably over time it'll taking
out it's very safe it's very un early
Jordan right well here's the difference
though where's the fun the fun is you
should set aside 5 to 10% of your money
and do exactly what you're saying have
fun speculate trade in and out but
listen you know what's fun retiring and
being freaking rich you know what sucks
it's no fun retiring and being freaking
poor okay as I always said in the movie
I've been Rich I've been poor I choose
Rich every time never look where are you
now thankfully I'm I'm wealthy how rich
are you now I don't want to say but I
thankfully do very well what can I guess
can you guess you can guess I if I was a
guessing man from when I last saw you to
now
uh 30 million okay well listen dollars
again um I do very very well am I in the
bull I don't want to say okay up or down
I I don't want to say or L I don't want
to say come on no I don't want aone I
really don't want to say I do very very
well why you say reent this is a guy
that used to boast about this time it's
because I you know I think that as an
older and wiser person right now I don't
think it's important how much I'm worth
okay what's important is I do really
well have everything I want people are
going to read your book The Wolf of
investing right I thoroughly enjoyed it
they're going to read this and go well
all right but how much is he worth it
because that will dictate whether I
believe you can go online and they have
my they have my net worth posted as 100
million I have is what it says I have no
idea how they got that figure no idea at
all but that's what it says why it says
it I have no idea so that's three times
what I guess but I have noide I'm not
say if it's right or wrong but that's
what the online says and I have no idea
why are you instructing me to go check
that online because you're cuz you're
pressing me I'm just kiding that's my
way out by the way but I'll tell you
this one thing no one ever accused me of
is not knowing how to make money I've
been accused of many things but I also
know never that but knowing you I also
know you would know how much you're
worth to the nearest Dollar right no
actually believe it or not I'm I'm not
like that that's more like my dad I was
never a counter of money I was just an
earner of money My Philosophy which I
don't suggest most people is you know
just make so much money that you don't
have to worry about spending money that
was always My
Philosophy they looked up my
with a freaking microscope right and you
know what they found after 5 years
zero we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online and we're on your smart
speaking criminals to using XL Bully
dogs as weapons to threaten others no
matter how well trained most dog owners
will tell you a dog can turn you know
what I love about to today
we do it all sunak sella
scon a woman can become a man and a man
can become a woman and if you think that
you're certifiably
insane slick Wishy seemed intelligent
forensic even a bit of a Statesman the
type of man you trust to look after your
house while you went on
holiday this concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry knives if they could go
and play Tiddly Winks at the you know
the corner of the street or whatever I
think it's a
nonsense happy th night we slick it
timorous Beast panic
in K stas accused the government of
failing a generation after a record
number of young people were killed last
year using a knife or sharp object we
need to make sure that when we say we're
going to ban them we actually do ban
them there are so many politicians now
who just said my D was a
BOS you're David Cameron no he
wasn't like brought to you by sadique
khah the mayor of London very rarely
meet anybody that says you know the
thing about London is it's got a great
mayor sadique khah brilliant
guy in the cities there are areas where
there are no vegetables it's
particularly difficult for those people
to do what Mark is saying if he comes up
with this argument again I'll sit on
him stop creating all of these funny
little factions with their funny little
names the new conservatives the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red prow
popcorn I mean popcorn what what is that
if you're talking about multiculturalism
it's workingclass white boys who get put
in the Army the poorest people in
society are the ones who are going to be
put on the front line something is going
horribly wrong we can do a lot better
Donald Trump didn't just win he
obliterated this is a guy facing nearly
a hundred criminal charges and yet all
that's done is actually make him more
popular Trump is canny enough to know
that all public publicity is good
publicity I don't want a president who's
been impeached if he's able to bamboozle
you that's the way it goes did my six
months I came back nobody would touch me
I put my head down I persisted I Carri
down when I say I am God I'm not joking
did you feel Elvis was controlling I've
been answering your question you answer
mine it's actually not my job to answer
your questions I've asked you two
questions should a mass stay EMP power
and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV the only place
where you get the truth you've done a
book on poetry poetry music for the many
I love poetry we can agree on
[Music]
that my godfather who's been very
successful he just said to me the only
bit advice I give you he said is get to
you money as soon as possible there you
go and I said what do you mean he went
to the extent where you have enough
money where you can tell anybody you and
walk away so someone in a job you've God
is giving you a hard time or whatever
and I've actually acted on this um you
can just literally walk away because you
you're not riant on that thing or that
person for money to buy food in the
morning well there's money and then
there's Elon Musk he literally
says the people to the people who he
needs to give money to X right that's
the real definition of but I agree but
listen let me just getting back to what
you said right the mistake people make
when they invest because I you're right
you have to have fun and that's and
specifically I say you should speculate
and I go through how to speculate
carefully have fun make money but the
bottom line is if you think that you can
take your money that you that you save
and speculate you can end up okay you're
not you're going to mostly get destroyed
because this the playing field is dram
atically tipped against you when you go
to a casino right and you walk into a
casino the odds are stacked against you
right so over time you're going to lose
you might win once while but over time
you lose but you might some people enjoy
going even if they lose money but it
gets worse though because this is not
just a casino Wall Street it's a corrupt
Casino where the dice are stack are
loaded the cards are being dealt from
the bottom of the deck so it's not a
fair playing field so it's a double
whammy it's the odds are against you
naturally and then it's also stacked
against you because it's corrupt there's
corruption there there and there's
things that are legal like short-term
high frequency trading there's inside
information all over the place there's
just you know better deals given to the
bigger investors so the answer is you
extract the value by investing in the
S&P 500 and by the way they're
constantly changing out companies so you
always have the best companies and then
you still have to fund by taking some
money that you have and go do whatever
you want you want to go buy and sell
crypto and tokens or nfts or do you
believe in Bitcoin yes I do believe in
Bitcoin I saw Jamie Diamond saying he
just thinks it's all hot air I knowen I
respectfully just I I once thought that
too okay I did but again when you look
at something like Bitcoin it's it's like
one of those things where truly the LIE
can become the truth if enough people
say it's true but isn't it isn't it a
case if there's enough mugs out there
they all trade it with each other it
will go up well well yes but over but
you have some really smart mugs these
days you know you have some of the you
know most sophisticated people starting
to embrace it so I think most of crypto
is complete bull currency I can
understand and Jamie Diamond was saying
that that you can use cryptocurrency in
a perfectly legitimate way and it's very
useful the actual system blockchain the
underlying technology the blockchain
technology yeah that that that
technology is very useful and is widely
used his argument was more about the
kind of Bitcoin stuff which just seems
to be based on a sack of sand well on
some level that's true but you can make
the same case for Fiat currencies where
they're printing dollars and just
printing more dollars anytime they see
fit the one thing about Bitcoin is a
finite amount of Bitcoin and I would
agree in the early days yes it was
mostly used for fraud and scamming and
evading it's not the case anymore
there's a lot of really sophisticated
people who are buying Bitcoin now that
it's has there's efts you know it's it's
it's completely it's you know ETFs by
it's it's completely change now so I
think Bitcoin is legit but the problem
is all these other coin and cryptos that
are worthless and they really been
they're like the penny stocks of crypto
and they're basically been issued by
people that want to separate others from
their money and those should be avoided
you mentioned penny stocks it was that
that led you down the wrong path wasn't
it yes that stuff early on and it ended
up with you losing your
Liberty what was the worst moment for
you when it all went wrong when you look
back what was the moment you would least
want to
relive when I was asked to wear a wire
and I did and it was a friend and I see
you see in the film and I slipped him a
note cuz I didn't want to rap I thought
I was being a standup guy so that's in
the movie right it's true and I thought
I was doing the right thing as you know
a man and I slipped the guy and know
saying don't incriminate yourself right
and I walked away from that saying you
know what I maintain my Integrity
because I'm not a rat and then three
months later they came back to me and
the guy ratted me out and at that moment
in time like literally I lost all faith
in humanity was facing 20 years in jail
they could have broken my agreement if
it was not for the FBI agent who
indicted me was a great guy he
understood and like they gave me a
second chance because that could have
destroyed my life that was the low point
for sure that moment when I you you
think like I'm not a rat and then you
it's so that's the Jonah Hill character
but that's not true it wasn't but in in
reality it was not the Jonah Hill
character it was they collapsed like
three or four people into that character
right it was someone else did you ever
have anything more to do with the one
that ratted you out you know saw him a
few times but no relationship any
forgiveness yeah of course I forgive I
don't I not want to hold grudges and I
forgive you know and uh you know you
don't forget but you certainly can but
that was worse for you than actually
going to
prison far worse than prison itself was
waiting to go to prison the thought of
it just the uncertainty in your life
you're almost dying in slow motion you
know once you go to prison you know
becomes almost a rebirth if you're will
to take that failure that life failure
and use it as a lesson to reinvent
yourself and and that's what I did I you
have a lot of time in prison to think
about stuff there's nothing else to do
for most of the day right yeah so I did
really two things I number one is I I I
thought about stuff a lot for sure but I
also taught myself to write and I use
that time to perfect my writing well not
perfect but just you know really become
a competent writer and that led me to
write The Wolf of Wall Street which then
launched this entirely new career so I
think the matter you know the lesson for
anyone listening is that you know
everyone up everyone makes mistakes some
people make much bigger mistakes than
others right would you change anything
no I mean when you look at where you've
got to now no I wouldn't the whole path
up and down and then back up would you
change it I wouldn't but that so let me
it's a complicated question so the
answer is no because it's not possible
of course if I could not have done
anything to hurt another person of
course I wish I never did that of course
I feel terrible about all that stuff and
I'm very remorseful for that okay and I
and and I've spent so many years making
up for that in countless ways but I
wouldn't change anything that was my
life and it happened and I've used that
as sort of like to create this life I
have now so if I could cherry pick it
and say you know I hope no one ever lost
money as my of course I do that I'm not
crazy right but you can't do that you
know you have to look back at your life
and say you know what this is what I did
I made mistakes I learned from those
mistakes and now I keep becoming a
better version of myself that's my goal
is to become a better version of myself
every day are you completely squeaky
clean now squeaky I mean sober clean or
clean with the law anyway sque I'm the
cleanest person you let me you know why
because I I would have to be in other
words you know you realize that I'm
going to be scrutinized more than
anybody and in fact I was for many years
the government thought I was not paying
my fine that I had they thought I was
hiding money they looked up my
with a freaking microscope right and you
know what they found after five years
zero so like Warren Buffett says they
you could follow anybody if a cop
follows you for 300 miles they'll give
you a speed ticket they couldn't give me
one and they follow me for for hundreds
of miles before you went into prison you
obviously had beautiful yachts and
private planes and all that kind of
thing which of those things do you still
have well I have beautiful I I fly
private often right on your own plane no
I Charter a plane which is getting
prohibitively expensive by the way which
is terrible you that's why I love the
Trump come back and lower prices for gas
would be a really good thing we'll come
to him yeah um I'm a fan you know not of
all things but generally speaking big
fan right um um I would never buy a
yacht again I was so happy when the one
I had sank it was like the great I was
so happy like I didn't plan it out but
when it was sink I was like yes Lloyds
of London you know right I worked at LD
right my first year of my working career
I to help a mate out I worked as on one
of the underwriting syndicates I would
have been one of those guys paying you
all that money for your yacht there you
go right I got a check for like $9
million a day it's said a few days later
they showed they like usually we
investigate these things but you know no
one will be stupid enough to go on the
boat themselves into a storm you just
here's a check and don't ever ask us to
insure you again basically they pay me
right away right so Lloyds was pretty
good to me so no boat but you you child
a private a private I listen I'm very
car yeah but I I do what do you drive a
Mercedes Mercedes and my wife has got an
Aston Martin which one uh she's got the
truck the dbx and I have the AMG the the
the GT Turbo whatever is AMG right I'm
going ask M guys but cars it's
interesting when I was in my 20s and 30s
I loved cars just meant everything to me
what car I drive I I honestly never even
now you're on Comfort I never drive even
like I I'll take a an Uber or something
you know just dri it's so much easier I
could just relax in the back seat so you
know all the a lot of the urges I had of
how I Define myself as a man so to speak
very different than the way I do today
do you ever get urges to just go and
take loads of quades and behave
disgracefully well yeah but qus yeah not
cocaine but qus were amazing thankfully
they're illegal and you can't find them
anywhere like thank God because they're
too good you know but if you have one
you know we can go after you I do not
just for the record I do not have any G
that's the one drug you know like and
people say listen I'm just kidding a
little but a little bit but they were
amazing thank God that you can't find
they were just so great that you know
very difficult to resist so your desires
can't be quenched oh you know again
probably could you yeah listen I I drink
a little bit here and there don't use
drugs uh the things that make sense in
your 20s and 30s don't make sense you
know it gets a more diff to recover when
you didn't have your Liberty what was
the thing you missed most about Liberty
freedom freedom just being Lally being
able to was it were the specific things
that when you when you when you came out
what were the things you most wanted to
do again first thing I did was I ate a
cheeseburger missed cheeseburgers
desperately right but I mean you
know it's very when you're in jail and I
was not in a terrible jail it wasn't
like I have to worry about you know
going into the shower and getting in the
shower it wasn't like that okay it was
it was a a minimum security but Jail's
jail you know you have no Freedom you
can't do what you want to do and there's
something about that that can be very
suffocating now the way I got around
that was just engrossing myself and
learning at a right and that passed the
time very quickly and I worked out a lot
got kept in shape but other than that
just the entire this this it's hard to
explain because you know there's
something about not having Freedom not
being able to do what you want to do
when you want to do it um is just is is
suffocating and it can be very for most
people it it can break them you know for
me I was able to turn that into energy
to write and and ended up really
Reinventing an entirely new
life I've never seen an uncanny sense of
what the average person needs to hear
yes he was a great
president it's the world's number one
interview show the new Global home were
big debates and big questions this is
really unfair why we'll explain why for
all the big names Donald Trump if you
choose to have someone who's the
criminal is President I have to accept
your choice did you feel Elvis was a
controlling influence I did my six
months I came back nobody would touch me
I put my head down and persisted and
carried on and the good news you've
already found it all new peers Morgan
uncensored right here Monday to Thursday
8:00
p.m. where we're here thanks for joining
us you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well do
you know what I love about talk today we
do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police appr Pro Palestine that is
just that's not right you swear an off
in the police to act without fear or
favor the co inquiry seems to have
turned into a sort of pantomim there's
not really any substance to it it's hard
to know whether it's a f or a tragedy
there needs to be one human per machine
to come and rectify beats and the clanks
and when it goes R unexpected item in
bagging area I know are we only going to
be trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from at Gram was president of the
Cambridge Union which is the rub version
of being president of the Oxford
un Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegans about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this is
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a
rational talk TV it's the only place
where you get the
truth
this is talk
[Music]
TV I mean it's been an amazing
reincarnation I've watched you like at
the Oxford Union and places like that
dazzling which was great by the way
great yeah and in fact they got you to
do the sell the pen thing again how many
times have you been asked to sell a pen
so many times you you ignited that I did
it I did it here's a pen in the movie we
see Jordan B sell a pen sell me the pen
I'm going to meet you halfway with this
and I'll give a little sales training
here about the Trap of selling a pen
Pierce how long have you been in the
market for a
pen uh I've wanted a pen for three
months so you've been looking for a pen
for three months now yes really and what
type of pens do you typically use when
you use a pen I like a nice easy to ous
bullo pen or something okay so now just
so you know what I'm doing so the I want
to teach a little bit here is that the
idea is that when you sell some on
something is you need to be asking
questions first I'm not going to do it
again uh but the thing about the pen it
wasn't really about the pen no you know
you would do the thing it was a very
effective stunt But ultimately it's
about if you're trying to sell something
don't say this is the best thing of all
time make sure you hone in on someone's
desires to want it and if they have a
desire to want it you're in exactly
that's that's salesmanship yeah who is
the best salesman you've ever seen me
that we would know apart from you apart
from me that we would know that you
would know wow Elon Musk is a hell of a
Salesman yeah I mean this he's selling
Big Dreams and you know and but is he a
Salesman so much as just a brilliant
engineer no he's well yes he's both I
mean I don't think Elon Musk is
necessarily A by salesman I think it's
someone who could sell you anything even
if the the actual thing he's selling is
not that great whereas musk I always
think there's a high quality control on
mustu he does right whether it's the
electric vehicles whether it's uh SpaceX
and stuff this is very high tech many of
this stuff things fail and don't work by
the way right so but the thing with Elon
Musk is is that he's able to get people
believing in him in his vision for the
future for sustained periods of time
yeah like if you go back to history of
SpaceX they were like this close to one
fail fail launch Tesla from Tesla to say
at the same time and the same's
happening with X and I would back him to
deliver it I would never discount him
with X by the way right so I I look at
him as being an amazing salesman and
Buffet by the way is another world class
sales person and communicating he
actually says that what changed his life
was took he took a course on sales and
persuation yeah back then it was Dale
Carnegie and it changed his life but
what does he sell really what do he well
in the early days you know what he would
be without his ability to sell and
persuade the the the most successful
unknown money manager from Omaha
Nebraska it was his ability to get his
message after to give him money to
invest in Berkshire haway Anders that
made him into what he is the the best
salesman I think out there for better or
worse is Donald
Trump no doubt I have never seen anybody
I've never met anyone like Trump and
I've known him a long time good bad
friendly not friendly you know we fall
in and out all the time but you cannot
deny that the Showmanship the energy the
competitive streak he has But ultimately
the salesmanship he is able to
crystallize messaging and deliver it in
a way that mass numbers of people can
understand relate to and support in a
way I haven't seen in any political
figure for a long time so I I think that
that yes it's true but he's also an
amazing marketer and promoter well is a
isn't marketing marketing and
salesmanship similar there's there two
sides Sim two sides of the same Co
marketing is sort of like bringing
someone to the next step in the process
right selling is actually closing the
deal if you look at Donald Trump I'll
tell you one thing he has that I've
never seen an uncanny sense of what the
average person needs to hear yes and
it's unbelievable you know very big
themes very simple themes repeating them
again and again again and he must be the
most resilient person I've ever met in
my entire life well I would I would say
he's the most thin skinned he'll react
to everything and resilient and thick
skinned yeah exactly skin is double
pronged the thinnest and the thickest of
anything I've ever seen in my life it's
incredible he soaks up stuff that would
kill off any other public figure again I
I thought when the whole thing with with
you know the whole thing with I touched
I thought that was I thought he was done
and I was baffled when he didn't even
apologize and I watched his numbers go
up right he never apologizes so and
actually there's a strength in that I
mean I've demanded he apologized
sometimes but afterwards when I see
people who do apologize it very rarely
does anything but make their situation
worse unless they sincerely are sorry
right and they've done something which
is clearly completely wrong know if you
were with Trump now you'd say that what
he said about that was just to and he
would he would mean that well here's the
thing though with Trump though he was a
great president the forget the Twitter
post okay I get that you might not like
a style of communication but look at the
world as it was when he was president
and look at the world today I mean you
know there were no Wars the economy was
roaring inflation was low he got killed
by Co so to speak and the mainstream
media and this whole I mean he went
through with this whole Russian
collusion nonsense right but the country
Trump's biggest problem is this yes he
gets himself the biggest problem but
that's also his greatest asset you know
I remember talking to him when he was uh
when he was elected the first time and
he said my my team want me to give up
Twitter what do you think I went why
would you it just got you elected right
and all right so I'm partly to blame
carrying on um but actually you know it
was it was that unfiltered our show is
called uncensored it was that unfiltered
uncensored style he had which cut
through all the normal Washington speak
people are smarter than many politicians
give them credit for and Trump you you
can hate him L but he speaks a lot of
truth about these important issues that
matter to the average he he's gut about
things like I saw Jamie Diamond
defending him exactly yeah and and it's
not because he's a massive Trump
supporter in fact he's he's financially
supported Democrats far more than
Republicans but he made the point if you
just attack all his supporters as
crazies right 7 million people
deplorables and so on you're missing the
point why they vote for him they're not
voting for him because they his Tweeting
or because they they like his personal
issues or whatever they're supporting
him because I think his gut feel for
things like not going to war for things
like the economy the tax reforms he
brought in the reform of NATO which
they're now all paying their dues all
that kind of stuff you know actually was
very effective yeah I think if it hadn't
been for Co he'd have been reelected
quite comfortably and and also was a
huge Miss in in the way the Republican
viewed mail and voting in other words
the mail and ballots right they shunned
it said oh no go down and vote an
election day and the Democrats embraced
it and you know you had 30 days of
voting versus one day of voting on the
Republican side so was a huge Miss in
tactics as well but yeah you're right if
it wasn't for KOB he most certainly
would have been can you divorce though
some of the affectedness of trump which
is undeniable with the more outrageous
stuff that comes out of his mouth and
the effect it has and I the example the
classic one being the way he fired up
that crowd on January the 6th and then
we saw the result of his rhetoric
actually manifesting itself in an
attempt to thwart democracy at the
capital I mean you can see a link when
you're the president of the United
States this matters yeah it does but you
know B I don't look at that as an
Insurrection I mean I don't know I mean
what would you call it I'll call a
moment of idiocy there was no chance
they were ever going to take over the
capital overthrow the government I think
they were trying pretty hard yeah I I I
don't I I think when people try and play
that down I'm like people died that day
yeah you know if you look back at how
many times Hillary Clinton said the
election was rigged it wasn't I mean
they both do it right and yeah he went a
little bit too far for sure but I don't
look at it as his democracy was you I
think the country's stronger than that
the constitution is more durable than
that than that day but whatever yes it
was wrong I don't agree with what he did
I if he wants to win again would you
like to see him what I to see is no war
in the Middle East I'd like to see no
war with Russia and Ukraine what I'd
like to see is low inflation what I'd
like to see is my taxes go down I like
to see the country energy independent
and thriving again and i' like to see
the world a safer better place for my
children and grandchildren that's what I
want to see and I don't care about that
I'm to I'm going to to put up with the
idiotic tweets because I want the
outcomes that are most important to
myself my family and everyone I love if
Joe Biden was working for
you would you still be employing him if
he worked for me in his current I i' put
him in a nursing home all due respect I
mean come on I mean I don't even really
think he's president it's like a cutout
it's a puppet I think everyone knows
that I mean this is embarrassing it's
embarrassing I have friends from all
over the world they're like what what's
wrong with your country like this is the
president of the United States the most
powerful country in the world he's
walking he's like I mean you know my mom
and by not just his age my mom is 91 and
can run intellectual circles around most
50 year olds something he was never that
sharp because when I was a kid he got
thrown out of the elections because he
of his plagiarism right Brit he he
actually who was the Brit that he stole
the uh yeah that's right he did yeah
right he so somehow he bounced back good
everyone can be resilient right but at
this point in time I mean it's painfully
obvious that he's not all there anymore
he's just not so you know they should
put a real candidate up there you know
who's running things there I'm not quite
sure I suspect it's probably Obama and
that whole crew still running things and
he's just like like who's the perfect
cutout we can just have that he'll do
whatever we say and that's really what
he is and why he was put up in the last
election has the world's biggest female
movie star Margo Robie thank you yet for
you propelling her career she did
really big opinions you can't be
concerned about these people coming cuz
that makes you a nasty racist big guests
and the big issues of the day join me
Julia Harley Brewer every day at 1: p.m.
when I'll be tackling the stories that
affect real people's lives these people
were effectively you know tried and
convicted by the court of public opinion
when did we stop of Innocence talk TV if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about
[Music]
it we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online and we're on your smart
speaking criminals to using XL Bully
dogs as weapons to threaten others no
matter how well trained most dog owners
will tell you a dog can turn you know
what I love about talk today we do it
all sunak sella scon
a woman can become a man and a man can
become a woman and if you think that
you're certifiably
insane slick Wishy seemed intelligent
forensic even a bit of a Statesman the
type of man you trust to look after your
house while you went on
holiday this concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry knives if they could go
and play Tiddly Winks at the you know
the corner of the street or whatever I
think it's a
nonsense happy Thursday we slick it K
and be open up panics
iny K stas accused the government of
failing a generation after a record
number of young people were killed last
year using a knife or sharp object we
need to make sure that when we say we're
going to ban them we actually do ban
them there are so many politicians now
who just say my dad was a
Bost you're David Cameron no he
wasn't was like brought to you by St KH
the mayor of London very rarely meet
anybody that says you know the thing
about London is it's got a great mayor
it's a deep CH brilliant
guy in the cities there are areas where
there are no vegetables it's
particularly difficult for those people
to do what Mark is saying if he comes up
with this argument again I'll sit on
him stop creating all of these funny
little factions with their funny little
names the new conservatives the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what
what is that if you're talking about
multiculturalism it's workingclass white
boys who get put in the Army the poorest
people in society are the ones who are
going to be put on the front line
something is going horribly wrong we can
do a lot better Donald Trump didn't just
win he obliterated this is a guy facing
nearly a hundred criminal charges and
yet all that's done is actually make him
more popular Trump is canny enough to
know that all publicity is good
publicity I don't want a president who's
been impeach if he's able to bamboozle
you that's the way it comes did my 6
months I came back nobody would touch me
I put my head down I persisted at C dong
when I say I am God I'm not joking did
you feel Elvis was controlling I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
questions I've asked you two questions
should a mass stay in power and are they
a terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry music for the many I love poetry
we can agree on
[Music]
that has the world's biggest female
movie star Margo Robbie thanked you yet
for you propelling her career she did
really yeah she did we had a really
funny uh situation where I was was in
Australia with my my when my my kids was
there going to school right and I pulled
in some random restaurant when was this
this is like six years ago and I pulled
to some random restaurant in the middle
of nowhere and she was we ended up in
the same restaurant in the Gold Coast of
Australia yeah and we hugged and she's
like oh my God you know wow what an
outcome and she's thank you it was the
great but let me tell you this though
you know she is incredibly talented yes
this is no accident and she's very smart
because she's also ucing this stuff
right through her her company which is's
now doing Gang Busters yeah I think if
it wouldn't have been the wood Wolf of
Wall Street it would have been something
else when you saw barbie grossing over a
billion you're like you know what Margot
that's on me without me this chain of
events doesn't happen yeah I I don't
really I think she would have been a
star no matter what I think she was
destined are you a Barbie fan no no not
because of the woke stuff I just didn't
like the movie I I don't like that I I
find it hard to buy once they mention
patriarchy for the 10 time oh my God
like you shut up besides I I don't like
the whole like there's too much
suspension of disbelief in me so you
know too difficult yeah I couldn't
really watch it I agree I found it but a
lot of people I know loved it yeah I I
can't see how because a lot of women
thought great this is makes women look
great Ken's an idiot I was hoping I
would like it by the way I wasn't hop I
wasn't wanting to hate it because it's
Margo I love Margo I wanted to love it
and then and it's start off okay and
then I was like oh my God this is just
like awful and especially at the ending
with the guitar singer
stop it want to kill myself I'm the same
I found it almost un really I'm like
really you know no I think she's a
brilliant actress I met her actually in
Oscar's party very Charming uh great
actress I think she's a very talented
person not just in on screen but the
production company she set up and
everything it's all great but I thought
Barbie sucked yeah it was just it was
horrendous it was bad have you seen Leah
since yeah yeah I saw yeah St him like 6
months ago yeah where was in KH Film
Festival we ran to each other what
happens when you see each other oh he
huged me he he said something really
nice he goes you know what I think we
made one of the last great movies he
goes like they can't make movies like
that he go can't they can't there would
be somebody from Human Resources saying
you can't have the a dwarf being thrown
at a velcro dboard you know what he said
also he goes I never saw Marty so happy
and at ease than when he was filming
that movie really he's usually much
different he was so happy and laughing
was just to watch Marty and I think on
some level the movie is an expression of
how much Marty enjoyed himself the whole
thing because I I find excuse me I find
so many movies now very boring I get
told they're brilliant yeah I sit and
try and watch them they we Hollywood
seems to have lost that ability to just
be pure entertainment one of the
exceptions top gum Maverick that was
great which was one of the a a great
sequel to a movie I loved but it was
just pure entertainment I went with two
of my sons in their 20s and we were like
punching the air and having a great
afternoon I was like that that's what
movie going should be I think of what
what's wrong a couple things number one
too much Reliance on special effects and
not enough on the story topot Maverick
had an amazing story yeah right but so
much of the stuff like even know I love
The Avengers then it got crazy with all
I mean with just too much CGI and then
the woke and you infused in so yeah I
think there's a a real problem right now
and you know I think TV shows are much
more interesting these days than movies
I found myself watching a lot more TV
streaming than movies and hopefully it
will change you know well the pandemic
changed of doing pants didn't it it did
well you know again and we ended up
watching every single movie ever made
and then got into box sets which were
great cuz they could last like three
four days you know I went to the movies
to see Top Gun I went to the theater for
I went to the theater the last time I
went to the movies was Top Gun me too
because I wanted to see it on a big
screen exactly so if it's great you'll
go when you see Davos the whole setup of
Davos what do you think of it I I think
it's it's really it's like the Oscars
for financial services people they get
to congratulate it happen no it they all
go in on their private planes and preach
about climate change it's it's we some
random woman from the Amazon rainforest
coughing on them right and I'm like what
am I watching here it's a networking
opportunity for rich people it's you
know a self congratulatory nonsensical
bunch of right and it's so out of touch
with the real problems of the world and
just you know I know that cuz John KY
went there so what does that say right
well he was jumped about because he uses
more private players than anybody in
history and there is a contradiction
there cuz I sort of think well the one
thing we learned in the pandemic other
than to watch everything on TV and
movies was we also learned that you
don't have to be with each other
physically to have a meeting yeah why if
you're having a meeting about things
like climate change as Kerrie does do
you not just do it remotely save your
carbon footprint he doesn't you can't
get the statue right right you know I
crashed his wife's plane Teresa you did
yeah yeah I charted that plane his I
think were married back then yeah and I
charted it and coming back from I think
St Martin many years ago and uh or St
Thomas and landed in a snow storm in
Farmingdale Long Island crashed the
plane really oh yeah yeah yeah you
nearly died on John car's wife's plane
yes yes true story that would have been
a great ending for you I know right you
got to I mean how are you how do you
want to end your life eventually I mean
obviously you're a long long way from it
but you've got to go out with a bang is
you you know hopefully in my sleep you
know I always say my wife hates the fly
right we're in a plane It's s the bounce
at hunting I'm not going to die in a
plane crash it would be way too
anti-climatic at this point I've been
through three plane crashes a yacht
sinking I mean it's not going to happen
like that so you know hopefully I'll die
many years from now asleep in my bed
with my children happy and healthy
that's my go and when you do how do you
want to be
remembered as the ultimate comeback
story ultimate Redemption
story yeah that's it I mean you know I
think and I think I'm really have done a
pretty good job at that and I think it
not just that I help people you know
with this book to invest more wisely or
my sales training book to sell more
effectively or be a better entrepreneur
I think also my life into itself serves
as inspiration to people who who who are
either you know made a mistake or
currently down on their luck or just
struggling and you you think like you
know what how do I come back from this
and what's the single most effective bit
of advice for people that are in that
position to get them back on
track that there's going to be typically
A specialized skill that you might have
to learn you might have to re-educate
yourself to learn something new and you
have to like you learn to write exactly
speak and everything else so there's
hard work but then there's doing hard
work that you don't like doing some hard
work people like you might like doing
something so you'll work really hard at
that embrace the stuff that you need to
embrace that maybe you don't like doing
you to train yourself to do things you
don't like doing to get the things that
you want most people skip that step they
you know like you're a famous newscast
right well you know how hard did you
work how much hard did you train how
much work did you do to get to that
point to to be great at interviewing
people to perfect your delivery there's
work to be done if you want to change
your life and you know you you have a
certain set of skills well guess what
chances are you're going to have to
learn or perfect a certain skill to get
the outcome you want don't just try to
have the plan do the work the hard work
in the beginning and that's the first
step I think to really changing your
life I also think just obviously the the
classic never give up is important but
also everything does pass I mean you've
seen that in your life and I always say
to my kids you know and they're from 12
to 30 now but however bad things seem in
the moment short of death everything is
recoverable yeah you can survive and
thrive whatever it is do you think yeah
I do but again I I get back because this
one missing thing that that that really
drives it is that you know it's not just
about hard work it's not never give up
because if you just keep doing the same
thing again and again it's about
changing own it's about it's something
about you you might have to change
something about yourself either learn a
new skill you know build yourself
emotionally become more resilient but
you can't just be the same person and
expect different results you have to
grow yourself and that and that's the
step I think most people Miss is they
don't invest in themselves whether it's
taking the right courses you could do it
online you could do it in person but
literally learning things that you have
to know to succeed in life and if you
don't have those things you'll keep
getting banging around maybe you'll get
some mediocre but the greatness lies in
making yourself great you have to be
great at something and then do the hard
work and then you'll get the result you
want so you've actually met a real wolf
right with the photographer David yo
good friend of I've done many photo
shoots with David in the beginning with
a real wolf ultimately with a hybrid
because he was getting some flak from
the animal people right so now it's not
full wolves but it's hybrid so it's more
friendly to the uh what whatever you
call the animal graes right okay but in
incredible stuff with David then
recently I was in Bali and an old friend
of mine believe it not he has a house he
keeps 22 wolves real wolves in his house
and it's just the more he walks around
these seven wolves and yeah I met all
are surrounded by wolves and they wolves
are not like dogs you don't tell a wolf
to sit he'll say you know wolves don't
wolves dance their own tune but they're
also beautiful and you know they don't
bite you per se but you know you don't
want to be around them when they're
hungry did you see any s arities between
you and actual Wolf character-wise the
characters they go on packs I had my
pack my wolf pack back then right it
wasn't just me I was the leader of the I
was the alpha wolf but you know you
always have a pack of wolves and wolves
are very intelligent they always find a
way that's the thing about wol they
always find a way and they'll kill
anything that gets in their way if it
gets in their way especially if they're
hungry great to see you Jordan you too
let's not leave it another 12 years I
enjoy for sure good to see
you
he's one of the biggest and most
controversial voices in American
politics frankly I don't believe in
proportionate response to terrorism I
believe that the way that you stop
terrorism is with wildly
disproportionate response I agree with
him so my question is today what is the
going great today for human life I mean
2014 was a great year for
Ben
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
talk today we do it all soon Act sella
gon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this Hammer
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
on to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with soel braan she's heading up one
side and rich is soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
has booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police are pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear an o in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for sadik Khan we're not stopping until
you stop
the amount of time it's taken the number
of illegal migrants currently sent by us
to Rwanda zil the amount of money it's
cost we're saying what are we saying
it's cost about 140 million £140 million
so far so40 million so far result nil
absolutely nil are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking Liv if you're walking towards me
and you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walked into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC mous
man MC Mouse man he should be easy
enough to catch this guy shouldn't he I
mean he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit president
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film